um they think it's stupid
they think we're stupid oh dating oh
dating so it serves no purpose it's it's
redundant doesn't make any sense your
grandpa your grandparents they got
married quickly had long relationships
dating doesn't work well then why aren't
you married
[Music]
what else have you been doing the last
15 years that's the difference
yes but it serves no long-term purpose
okay
so when do you say what do you want from
a guy well the question you say is
question ask yourself is what you're
doing are you dating for purpose why are
you dating what what is your end goal
from david so i have to ask this on a
date so if i'm on the first one
what day why are you dating somebody why
are you going on dates what is what do
you want from dating to meet someone i
like for what what what what's it what's
the end game
husband
right so you then have to when you meet
a guy you have to be explicit and say to
say to him i'm dating to be married
okay if he's not going to be married and
he's wasting your [ __ ] time
so like how would you know that from the
philippines
but
you don't guess you don't assume
you meet him in a bar you meet him
online
i am only dating to be married if you're
not on this you waste that's not there's
not waste money but when you say like
that kind of like scary yeah that's
what's gonna that's what's gonna say it
scares a lot of us off but i don't wanna
be like married like now like i'm saying
like could be like four to five years
like that's the end game
yeah fair relationship long term well
every four to five years if you don't if
not say if you're not explicit in your
and what you went as an outcome every
time you meet somebody you're just
drifting along
you might be around four or five years
so you wasted a year of someone who was
never interested in getting married in
the first place so if you're not
explicit about what you expect as an
outcome then how can the outcomes you
want you need to be you say right this
is what i want
if you're not on this plan then there's
no point you join you know no point you
talk to me because this is what one at
the end of it yeah but like lies in the
audience don't you think it's a bit like
a bit overbearing so on the first date
if someone says to like oh like i want
to get married and someone has to kind
of like gauge if they want to get
married
you only get married i said to you i'm
dating to be mad i'm only dating to be
married but i think i don't want to
marry you but i'm only dating
an intention
a bit too high i feel like it makes that
puts a lot of pressure no no but you're
what you're doing is filtering the guys
who have no intention of being married i
guess it's just something
i would say like even even mentioning
like the word married would freak him
out and it would freak me out if a girl
was like yeah i like i don't remember
what does dana go and he was like oh
like he was talking about like a
proposal like on the first date yeah it
really freaked me out even though i was
i had similar intentions if you know
what i mean i would say like you know
when the first thing you would say like
oh like i'm trying to get in a
relationship and then you know maybe a
few days later you can be like oh like
do you ever oh there we go yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah um
oh like you know are you maybe like
looking to get married but you wouldn't
say it on the first date yeah that's not
really a first date i don't think it's a
discussion then i'm gonna tell you both
you're very wrong and you're very flawed
and never gonna if that's what you want
you're not gonna get weight when i laugh
you're gonna go through life just
drifting
but so i mean i'm telling you that you
know men do get scared
i think men also have autonomy in like
what's going on in the relationship and
i feel like the man just like okay
because the woman hasn't said
explicitly that she wants to get married
that it's off the table i think a man
should be able to also make that
decision as well so i feel like just
saying putting the whole thing in the
woman's hand is probably not fair you
missing something i'm not saying to you
you want to marry him i'm not saying
you're going to propose to him i'm just
going to make it clear for example i
don't want children right so whenever i
meet somebody that make it absolutely
[ __ ] clear that it's not going to
happen
if you're going to date me knowing that
that's fine i mean i respect that i
respect that that's the same thing so if
you know you want to be married if not
as to what you want out of life then why
are you dating guys that doesn't want to
be married
well i don't know but you don't know
because you don't tell them that's what
that's what you want
i guess do you think that's common
though i don't think it's like no i'm an
etiquette for a first date no no and i
just why you floss white women that's
why you float that's why no but i'm i'm
talking about
let me finish
um
i'm talking about the people i know that
are married
most of like my uh my brother is
i would say gonna get engaged this year
he's 28
yeah he's
like and the way like they he him and
his girlfriend just like met in college
dated for four or five years and like
now they bought a house probably gonna
get married
um and like same with my other brother
it was like the same thing
so i just like i don't know i'm not
saying you're wrong to be honest because
i actually like agree with you on some
level
but like devil's advocate i don't know
anyone that did that that got married
and that's like my parents that's how
they they met in college dated four or
five years yeah
even they're also married
so you're probably different generations
so what i say to you well this is like
my brother's 28 like that's the same
generation
don't try it don't try she's on you
she's on youtube don't try it
she's landing a couple
what would i say in response to that is
this
so how would you react if someone said
like i want to get my intention is to
marry on the first date like how would
everyone react to that because i feel
like that's what hey that's
like what are you doing
how's your response
where'd you go from that time in a place
you would say time i'm gonna play
something
yeah like i'm sorry there was like what
is it i was on the first date and like
this guy he never mentioned married but
he was like oh yeah like i'm trying to
like travel the world with my
significant other i'm like
i'm like i don't know you like why
like what yeah
now for me it's like
a time in the place is not necessarily i
take it as face value what i mean by
that is
if someone tells you it comes up to me
you know like wait on the thursday and
says oh i'm dating to get married cool
a big turnout personally for me is when
a woman knows like what she wants so if
i tell you time in the place i will i
really mean it's like look i'm looking
to get married in the next this amount
of time i'm looking to do it like this i
want this like i would know what i want
out of this out of a relationship and
stuff like that that's a really big
turnout for me personally turn off or
turn up turn on
you know what you want out of this
relationship i know what i want to when
i go into a relationship i know what i
want i want you know i want to i want to
date i want to you know have someone to
come back home to you to to marry to
love to have kids to build a family in
the next
eight years
right but i know that right and when a
woman comes along with the same energy
that is just a really big plus
i guess it can work out really well if
you're both on the same level so if the
person also has like that same intent
and is very forward as well then i think
it makes a lot of sense but i just don't
think in the uk we have that kind of
culture to be that forward so it just
comes across a bit
a bit strange actually so someone else
so you want to be married do you want to
be married at some point not a married
man but like in a very committed
relationship
for what yeah i won't get married
you're so cute
time in the place
time and place before
before you have that time before it's in
mind
before 30 yeah okay hopefully yeah
do you have a time and place in mind it
is eight years i wasn't saying did you
just discuss it yeah
look
when i first started thinking about it i
was like
like very young yeah but like my my
friend was like like just joking around
and i said i was like i want to be
have a kid when married like bef so when
my kid is born i can still be the you
know the cool dad
you know someone that you're that you
know i don't want to be that guy that's
like oh dad let's go throw a ball and
i'm and i'm like oh rusty like walking
around like
it's this bad thing oh
you want to
i want to be active i want to you know
pick my son up and like outrun him in a
race and be man then talk [ __ ] to him
when he's young you know i want to be
that dad i don't want to be that dad
that sits on the couch all day drinking
beer and watching tv no that's not no
[ __ ] speaking facts such
ladies do and if you've had like friends
in their 30s yes
yeah i don't think i do they're friends
and authorities that are unmarried but
would like to have been married already
or want to be married
um so far i mean so far i don't really
know i think they want to have kids but
they don't necessarily want to get
married they're more like they've gone
past that point
i mean i don't know yeah we haven't
really had that discussion but i mean
she's single and she's dating
or like in kind of like talking to
someone you know like whatever that's
someone because there's like a marriage
inflation with our generation like i
feel like every generation seems to get
married later and settle down a bit
later so i feel like we need to like
like i should face that in mind and
probably not want to get married so
early i think before 30 might be a bit
too much optimistic actually i think
you're flawed because i think i think
your opinion on that is flawed okay
explain
i can explain
sadly when how old do you think you
should how would you think you should
have children i think the best day just
probably is young like
above 18 but below 30.
so if you want to be have children
before why do you be married why do you
have children before you are married
i don't think it matters it greatly
matters why i mean it depends on what
your values are because you have more
security from a husband
if he walks away from you after your
marriage you still you have much more
rights to him than than if you're not
married
yeah i guess half your sheets i know
what you meant
and significantly more likely
self-sufficient and i wouldn't need to
marry someone to have that security so
let's say security is not an issue
having kids work before or after
marriage doesn't really make a
difference so
statistics shows that people who come
from marriage or generally speaking dual
parent house comps households say
children don't know those upbringings
have a better output in life than
children from single parent households
for yours but you won't be ashamed
you'll still be in a marriage but you're
just married after you've had the child
but why did i wait right so let me let
me
it doesn't matter what's the bigger
commitment having someone's name or
giving someone a child what's the bigger
commitment well can you repeat that
what's the bigger commitment given
somebody's being married or having a
child what is a bigger choice in life
i think it's having the child so why do
you have the harder thing before the
easier thing
i just because it doesn't matter when
you do the easy thing but if it's easy
to do the easy thing first no
i think it doesn't matter
you might get married not like him and
then divorce him no big deal we have a
child someone you don't like anymore you
still touch him for 18 years so why do
you have the child first about being
married
i don't think that makes much sense i
think you can get divorced after if you
don't like the person wait is that going
to be get divorced yeah no child is easy
that's at the expense of the child that
is true i think divorce has a
significant effect on the child and i do
think that if you grow up in a single
parent household you do have a different
sort of childhood because one parent
doesn't have the other person to like
bounce off like they can be too strict
or too lacks and i do think that's a
real thing
but i do think that you can get married
and be in a committed relationship
and have a child and then without a
child also be in a committed
relationship with the child you know i
think you missed a question i asked if
you give me an honest respect for you if
you miss questions
if marriage is easy
before we forget the children for now
you're married someone it doesn't work
out after three or four years you walk
away no problems yeah right
that's easy
having a child or somewhere ever you're
married you have to try someone wherever
that guy's a dick and you hate him after
a year he realized he wasn't the one for
you yeah right you're still have a link
to that man for 18 years at least so why
would you get mad why would you not get
married first
and will could maybe be able to walk
away with a lesser commitment then have
a child with a greater commitment i feel
like somebody that's like kind of a
special case i haven't really i mean i
don't know really what situations are
but i feel like usually when you have
the child before me are just like not
intentional maybe like my people like my
parents had
i mean that's not a bad thing and then
you can like you can still like
like i mean obviously you still like
choose to keep it but i mean it doesn't
i feel like it's just a special case i
think that now that we're having
children so much later in life yeah i
feel like it doesn't matter so we're a
bit mature like the average age to have
a child now it's probably a lot older
than my parents would have a child i
think that's why it doesn't really
matter when exactly the child is born
because normally it's later than the
average anyway our parents
i just think like you can't there's no
way you can accidentally have a child in
2022
you know you do all the right things and
then you still get pregnant and like you
know maybe they don't want to have the
abortion so they choose to have the kid
but then you know they don't feel like
quite ready they're going to be unhappy
so you're telling me like condoms and
birth control you know someone that's
gotten pregnant on both but also i mean
like not everyone takes birth control
not everyone wears condoms that's oh
we're in the uk now right i don't know
how it is for your international
students
but in the uk
and i'll stand by this and people can
ask me what they want to
you cannot have a baby packs in the uk
you can have a word you cannot you can
say it you can not have a child by
accident in the uk
well i mean i used to have a child in
the uk because yeah contraception is
free condoms the pills we're getting
wait wait wait let me finish condoms are
free the pill is free
if you don't have that you have you get
reckless
one nafta is free
everything in the uk in terms of
reproductive rights are free so if you
choose to do any of those things you
have made a conscious decision to have a
child yes over here you cannot try
backstage but i didn't say by accident i
said unintentionally
so you can't no it's not because yeah
like naivety like something can happen
that you're not aware of let's say
you're not conscious well let's say like
you
are very naive you don't know to monitor
your cycle you don't know if you've
missed a period some people just don't
pay attention to those things there's
people who have abortions are free
yeah some people don't even know they're
pregnant yeah so like abortion so you
chose to have a child but okay but
that's the thing
you choose you choose oh you let me talk
so i'm not saying like it was by
accident i'm saying they unintentionally
got pregnant and then they chose
against their values to like have an
abortion so like it wasn't even a choice
let's say
yeah
it's not a choice but some some people
it's not even choice they wouldn't think
about having an abortion it's not on the
table let's say they're very catholic
well that's that's how my parents were
but but but you could
no um like my parents my parents my mom
got pregnant when she was um 17 but she
still chose to give up that kid for
adoption so like you still have adoption
even if you have the kid do you know in
the bible it talks about having adopted
um having abortions
i don't know where that's coming from
like
whether the numbers directly i believe
numbers nine says if you're up and
someone can look it up and give the
exact bible a reference well i think
it's number nine is something says
something in the lines of if you have a
wife and you believe she is cheating as
a baby she should go see like a witch
doctor take a potion and get rid of the
baby so the bible talks about having a
baby
what does that mean for people that
aren't religious like you're saying that
you put religion up i didn't bring
religion out who brought up having a
abuser you abusive i did say i mentioned
that some people don't believe that what
i'm saying some people like that she's
saying that some people don't believe in
abortion so that's why they choose to do
it some people can't afford some people
can't afford an abortion so let's say
this doesn't take no but you know you're
in the uh but we're talking about the
yeah how about only these two i'm just
saying in the uk there's not the funding
of it isn't an issue because you have
the nhs you have to worry about the
funding of it it's not that's not a it's
not a debate with but some you know what
is there some [ __ ] some some fears some
females choose to like keep the baby for
the food like
it's it's the right reasons for them but
it's the wrong reasons for the guy
because what they're doing is like
um you got me pregnant
i'm gonna keep the baby and i'm just
gonna you know graciously accept your
child donations every month they do you
know you don't mean that but if you're
saying like if they're not married yet
so then and you said that only once
you're married then they actually have
like something you have to pick child
support regardless you have to support
but regardless you're entitled to more
as a wife than your mother
yeah like because for example my parents
had me there wasn't like they wasn't
married when they had me as well so
but you also have adoption like you can
give up a kid for adoption if you don't
believe in abortion
that's what my parents did
[Music]
poor greg